all right so where we left off we had
simplified our algebraic expression for
the squared error to the line from the n
data points and we kind of visualize
this expression right here would be a
surface in I guess you could view it as
a surface in three dimensions where for
any M and B is going to be a point on
that surface that represents the squared
error for that line and our goal is to
find the M and the B which would define
an actual line to find the M and B that
minimize the squared error and the way
that we do that is we find a point where
the partial derivative of the squared
error with respect to M is zero and the
partial derivative with respect to B is
also equal to zero so it's flat with
respect to M so that means that the
slope in this direction is going to be
flat let me do it in the same color so
the slope in this direction that's the
partial derivative with respect to M is
going to be flat it's not going to
change in that direction and the partial
derivative with respect to B is going to
be flat so this the it will be a flat
point right over there the slope at that
point in that direction will also be 0
and that is our minimum point so let's
figure out the M and B's that give us
this so if I take the partial derivative
of this expression with respect to M so
the partial derivative of this
expression with respect to M well this
first term has no m terms in it so it's
a constant from the point of view of M
and just as a reminder partial
derivatives it's just like taking a
regular derivative and you're just
assuming that everything but the
variable that you're taking the partial
derivative with respect to you're
assuming everything else is a constant
so in this expression all the X is the
Y's the B's the ends those are all
constant the only variable when we take
the partial derivative with respect to M
that matters is the M so this is a
constant there's no m here this term
right over here we're taking with
respect to M we're taking with respect
to M so the derivative of this with
respect to M is negative 2 it's kind of
the coefficients on the M so negative 2
times n times the mean of the x wise
that's the partial of this with respect
to M and then this term right here this
term right here has no M's in it so it's
it's constant with respect to M so it's
partial derivative
with respect to M is zero then this term
here you have n X n times the mean of
the x squared times M squared so this is
going to be we're technically a partial
derivative with respect to M so it's
going to be 2 times so it's going to be
plus 2 times 2 times n times the mean of
the X Squared's times M right the the
derivative of M squared is 2m and then
you just have this coefficient there as
well now this term you also have an M
over there so let's see this if we
everything else is just kind of a
coefficient on this M so the derivative
with respect to M is to be n times the
mean of the X is if I took the
derivative of 3m the derivative is just
the is just 3 it's just the coefficient
on it and then finally this is a
constant with respect to M so we don't
see it and so this is the partial
derivative with respect to M that's that
right over there and we want to set this
equal to 0 now let's do the same thing
with respect to B this term once again
is a constant from the perspective of B
there's no B here there is no B over
here so the partial derivatives of
either of these with respect to B is 0
then over here you have a negative 2n
times the mean of wise as a coefficient
on a B so the partial derivative with
respect to B is going to be minus 2n or
negative 2n times the mean of the Y's
and then there's no B over here that we
do have a B over here so it's plus 2m n
times the mean of the X is plus 2 m n 2m
n times the mean of the X's this is
essentially the coefficient on the B
over here was written in a in a mixed
order but all of these are constants
from the point of view of be there the
coefficient in front of the B the
partial derivative of that with respect
to B is just going to be the coefficient
and then finally the partial derivative
of this with respect to B is going to be
2n B or 2n v to the first you could even
say 2 to be + or 2n B is the partial
derivative of that with respect to B and
we want to set this equal to 0 so it
looks very complicated but remember
we're just
trying to solve for the MS and the bees
and we have two equations with two
unknowns here we have the MS we have the
MS and then we have the bees and I
simplify this both of these equations
actually the top one and the bottom one
our both sides are divisible by 2n I
mean 0 is divisible by anything it'll be
just 0 so let's divide the top equation
by 2n and see what we get if we divide
the top equation by 2n we can even see
it here this will become just one that
goes away and then those go away and you
would just be left with you are left
with negative times the mean the
negative mean of the X YS plus plus M
times the mean of X of the X Squared's M
times the mean of the X Squared's plus B
times the mean of the X's is equal to 0
that's this first expression when you
divide both sides by negative 2n and
then the second expression will be this
will go away this is when you divide it
by 2n I don't want to say negative 2 1
that's when you divided by 2n you get
this and we divide this by 2 and that'll
go away that will go away and then those
will go away and you're just left with
negative the negative mean of the Y's
plus M times the mean of the X is M
times the mean of the X's plus B plus B
is equal to 0 so if we find the M and
the B values that satisfy the system of
equations we have minimized
we have minimized the squared error and
we could just solve in a traditional way
but I want to rewrite this because I
think it's kind of interesting to see to
see what these really represent so let's
add this mean of the x wise to both
sides of this top equation and then
we're going to have so if way if we add
the mean of the x wise to both sides of
this top equation what do we get we get
M we get M times the mean of the X
Squared's plus B times the mean of the
X's plus B times the mean of the X's is
equal to these are going to cancel out
as equal to the mean is equal to the me
of the XY z-- that's that top equation
this bottom equation right here let's
add the mean let's add the mean of Y to
both sides of this equation and I do
that so that that cancels out and then
we're left with M do that in the blue
color show you the same equation we have
M times the mean of the X's plus B plus
B is equal to is equal to the mean is
equal to the mean of the Y's now I
actually want to get both of these into
MX plus B form this is actually already
there actually you can see that if our
line if our if our best fitting line is
going to be Y is equal to M X plus B we
still have to find the M and the B but
we see on that best fitting line because
the M and the B that satisfy both of
these equations are going to be the M
and the B on that best fitting line so
that best fitting line actually contains
the point it actually contains the point
and we get this from from the second
equation right here it contains the
point or the point I should write it
this way the coordinate mean of x mean
of y mean of Y lies on this point lies
on I should say lies on the line and you
could see it right over here you if you
put the mean of X in this for the
optimal M and B for the optimal M and B
you are going to get D you are going to
get the mean of the Y so that's
interesting this optimal line the
optimal line let's never forget what
we're even trying to do this optimal
line is going to contain some point on
it it's going to contain some point on
let me do that in a new color it's going
to contain some point on it right here
that is the mean of all of the X values
the mean of all the X values and the
mean of all the Y values that's just
interesting and it kind of makes sense
it kind of makes intuitive sense now
this other thing just to kind of get it
in the same point of view and then it'll
actually make become kind of an easier
way to solve the system you could solve
this a million different ways but just
just to give us an intuition of what
even is going on here what's another
point that's on that line because
you have two points on the line you know
what the equation of the line is going
to be well the other point if we we want
this to be an MX plus B form so let's
divide both sides of this equation by
this term right here by the mean of the
X's and if we do that we get M times M
times the mean of the X Squared's
divided divided by the mean of the X's
plus B plus B is equal to the mean of
the X why's the mean of the XY is
divided by the mean of the X's and so
when you write it in this form this is
the exact same equation as that I just
divided both sides by the mean of the
X's you get another interesting point
that will lie on this optimal this
optimal fitting line at least from the
point of view of the squared distances
so another point that will lie on it so
another point that will lie on this
optimal line is going to be the point is
going to be the point the x value is
going to be this so it's going to be the
coordinate the mean of the X Squared's
divided by the mean of the X's and then
the Y value is going to be the mean of
the X Y's divided by the mean of the X's
and I'll let you think about that a
little bit more but already this is
actually the two points that lie on the
line so both of these on the line both
of these on the on the best fitting line
on the best fitting line based on based
on how we're measuring a good fit which
is the squared distance these are on the
line that minimize that squared distance
what I'm gonna do in the next video this
is turning into like a 6 or 7 video saga
on trying to prove the best fitting line
or finding the formula for the best
fitting line but it's interesting
there's all sorts of kind of neat little
mathematical things to ponder over here
but in the next video we can actually
use this information we could have just
solved the system straight up but we can
actually use this information right here
to solve for our M and B maybe we'll do
it both ways depending on my mood